[Music]
Kim Possible so the drama is very
appropriately titled because there is
actually not as much comedy and as I
would expect the focus this time around
is still a lot of action but this time
more about changing relationships I
personally prefer the comedy more but
this is still pretty good after a big
action sequence between Kim Drakon and
she go come on a gal of anything that
pays homage to Tim Burton's Batman we
discovered that Kim on top of saving the
world is going through some high school
problems the biggest one being who's she
gonna take to the prom in most movies
this would be a really lame subject to
focus on but this time around it's about
asking her best friend Ron is it worth
it are they ready to take the next step
is that even the next step well trying
to figure out where their relationship
is going a new boy arrives to school who
seems identical to Ron except he's
good-looking and let's be honest a
little less annoying Kim thinks maybe
she doesn't have to sacrifice her
friendship with rod but Ron is not too
sure for far to me strange things are
happening like his favorite taco
restaurant is being changed designs for
toys are being stolen by super villains
and yeah maybe he thinks his
relationship with Kim should change too
it's looking more and more like this is
all part of drakken's diabolical plan
which apparently even Chico can't figure
out which is also part of his plan
because if she can't figure it out Kim
won't figure it out
even though let's be honest the plan is
pretty easy to figure out but kids show
gotta give a little leeway and speaking
of Lee wait you have to give quite a bit
to this movie when you find out there's
not as much comedy as there usually is
week impossible but to be fair what they
sacrifice it for kind of makes sense the
first film really was not story driven
it was just an excuse to have a bunch of
jokes based on characters this one slows
it down with only two villains this time
only one diabolical plan as well as
pacing an investment that's very much
like well a movie this time it feels
like there's a little bit more weight to
what's going on it's kind of a bigger
story it takes its time it lets the
characters breathe some might find that
as a turn-off as they just want to see
more jokes but seeing healthy thought
this was going to be the last thing Kim
Possible related it actually was until
they got renewed for another season this
somewhat serious tone is not a bad one
to go out on I give them credit that
they actually want to make a movie this
time
unlike the last one which while I enjoy
it immensely even I can acknowledge it
was just kind of a long episode I'm glad
that this story while predictable is
done in a way why actually enjoy seeing
these characters go through these
dilemmas both Kim and Ron at times act a
little selfish but it's never to a point
where we dislike them it's
understandable that age is
understandable that's never to a point
where it feels cliched or forced it's
not the thing where one person is
obviously in love with the other and one
just doesn't see it and they go over the
top and all that stupid stuff they both
kind of don't know whether or not they
want to move forward if this is a
relationship that they should be lovey
dovey about or should just stay friends
you legitimately feel the relationship
they've had for years and years but act
with all that how's the stuff you
usually expect from Kim Possible the
gadgets the action the one-liners for
the most part they step it up but again
in a kind of different way a way that
feels more like a movie this opening
action sequence for example is done much
slower than most of the other action
sequences but that's done so that it
feels larger these backgrounds are about
as simple as they can be but when you
notice how they're positioned and how
they shoot them and how every action
that they have feels like they're
actually going through it it's very
impressively done even the intro is
obviously analyzed to James Bond movies
but again they kind of give it that Kim
Possible feel I really like these shows
and movies that can take something that
exists pay homage to it but still kind
of make it its own thing it's kinda like
what Heath Ledger did with the Joker
it's kind of all the Joker's but it's
also its own thing at the same time I
appreciate something that can do that
very smoothly the jokes when they have
them are good there's just not as many
as there usually are we still get dragon
and shego bickering we get Ron obsessing
over something stupid and Kim with the
last-minute rescues and great one-liners
and I have to give credit that at least
in the movies again I haven't seen too
much of the show Ron is not just a
sidekick he legitimately helps out and
he helps out in ways that make sense to
his character they never feel forced
I've seen this kind of character so
often turned into a pain in the ass but
he's legitimately helpful okay at times
he can be a little grating but for the
most part I think it works with the
story animation action and characters
all taking on more of a cinematic tone
you get a Kim Possible movie that's
friend than what you'd expect especially
comparing it to the last one but it's
still reasonably well done I think I
probably rather watch the last one for
more laughs but for a final movie this
one gets it pretty good figure out the
stitch and give it a watch